alex fletcher says hey jason what are
common salary ranges for seed stage
founders you've seen
okay seed stage for those of you don't
know would mean you've probably raised
we're saying it's a seed
funded company so let's just say a seed
stage company would typically raise 750
to 3 million so we'll pick a number 1.5
million it would typically have a team
of six or seven people
six or seven people
the salaries are ninety percent of what
you're going to spend and you want to
have 18 months of runway 18 months of
runway into 1.5 million is about 90k a
month 80k a month let's put it at 80k a
month you got 78 people like i said that
means 10k per person all in
uh the variable for your benefits is
typically a plus
15 to 25 on your salary which means
you're netting out to seven to eight k
per month per employee
of cash compensation two or three k
per employee in non-cash compensation
benefits
that means
7.5
hey a month times 10 months is 75 plus
another 15 is 90. 90k
90k is reasonable yeah i would say um if
you went to your
um
vcs or your student investors and said
i'm going to pay myself 90k
um
and
i have got eight employees and you know
there's a developer getting paid 125 and
there's you know some sales execs or
product managers getting paid 50 60 70.
you know you that would be i think in
the range uh no that's not facebook
level google level or silicon valley
level this is working from home
this is working outside of the major
city known as san francisco
and so these are low salaries people
typically take a hit on their salary to
work at a startup because they get
options and so that would explain it and
in another world when i was coming up in
startups
it was pretty typical for a founder to
do something called the draw
i don't recommend this but they would
take a 2k 3k a month draw in other words
you take 2k 3k in cash out of the
company every month and
you know you shouldn't do this you're
supposed to pay taxes with my income tax
irs doesn't like you doing this but they
say i take a 203k draw just to pay my
expenses
um and they would put their apartment or
something against those expenses you
really don't want to do that i've seen
people do this and i've had to like tell
them like clean this up and pay your
taxes that should be income and you
should pay income taxes on it when you
pay your personal expenses from a draw
you're you're basically circumventing
the income tax law and leona helmsley i
think that's what she got busted for
eventually was she was putting all of
her personal expenses on her companies
can't do that you know you could
do it you know you could buy a lunch
here or there you could
take one third of your apartment if that
was your workspace and you could talk to
your accountant about that i think you
can take
some a percentage of your workspace and
and make that uh tax deductible but
back in the day
people expected a founder to take no
salary in some cases or 50k a year and
that everybody in the company would be
paid more than the founder
and you would be ramen profitable or you
would
basically take a salary or a draw that
was equivalent to enough for you to eat
ramen
but we're in a peak market right now
with peak entitlement and peak amount of
money slushing around i've seen founders
pay themselves 150k uh
and
uh that doesn't sit well with a lot of
the same investors feels like you're
flushing a lot of money very quick and
maybe you should take 90k
you know put that 60k towards an
incremental sales executive or an sdr or
if you've got sdrs offshore and they
cost 30k or 25k maybe get two offshore
sdrs sales development reps so that's
really what you're looking for is a
thoughtful process for picking that
salary and listen sometimes you know the
person's got
three kids and a mortgage and they can
only be an entrepreneur if they have a
200k salary and some venture firms will
be like okay we want to see you
be a founder and
we're willing to to do that so it's a
it's a discussion with your investors if
it's above 100k i'd say for a seat state
startup i'd have a little discussion
with your top investors hey here's my
thinking are you comfortable with that
and it's really about you being
thoughtful about the runway and hitting
your milestones and keeping the company
solvent the company's solvent you're
making money nobody really cares until
it hits 250 you know like when it hits
250 it's like whoa this is a big number
like you're working at google or
facebook at startups you're supposed to
be the opposite of that okay
i'm just telling you the reality it's
not my personal view necessarily